[Music]
foreign
let's start at the top so inception's a
movie that I absolutely love why this
was nothing like I'd ever seen before
and it completely blew my mind
since first seeing it all the way back
in 2010 it stuck with me ever since and
it's been a film that I constantly
revisit though Christopher Nolan will
likely go down as the man who made The
Dark Knight I think all in all that this
is his best film written and directed by
him it feels like the quintessential
Nolan film and it deals with all the
techniques that he's now known for
there's a focus on a high level concept
non-chronological storytelling and major
action set pieces with a big ensemble
cast man brought together his dream team
pun not intended and you can see why
he's continued to work with so many of
these actors like The Dark Knight Nolan
shot the entire movie himself without
ever using a second unit director and in
case you don't know this is basically a
norm in Hollywood what filmmakers often
do is that they'll shoot the Big scenes
and someone else will go off and do
other things that take up a lot of time
however you can tell that he put us all
into this and initially when he pitched
it he thought he'd have this script
ready in a month eight years later he
finally finished it off and the movie is
absolutely meticulous from the top to
bottom I broke down the film all the way
back in 2020 but I just had to return to
it and unearth all the details that I've
noticed since we will be covering some
of the things I talked about in that and
I also want to go over the potentially
hidden twist laid in the movie either
way this is going to be classes are
ultimate breakdown and this video we're
gonna discuss it all by about what I
want to talk about up top is the
ambiguous ending that left a lot of
people dreaming up their Theory times on
what's going on coming out the cinema
the biggest debate was whether cop
returned home or if he was actually just
stuck in a dream imagining it all now
this is something Nolan's actually
cleared up and he confirmed that in the
end Cobb made it out there's a little
detail hidden in the movie that Nolan
has stated shows what's going on
throughout the film whenever the
characters in a dream he can be seen
wearing his wedding ring whereas when
he's awake he doesn't this is because
his wife Mallory is very much alive when
he's sedated and thus he doesn't want to
quite Cast Away the memory of her she
represents a guilt that he feels over
causing her death because he did his own
Inception in to make a disregard reality
trapped in a dream with Cobb for over 50
years the only way to escape this was by
seemingly getting killed this allowed
them to wake up and travel back into the
real world but Cobb planted the idea
that they just gonna belayer their smile
invited cabal to once more die together
but unfortunately for her this whole
thing was actually real a cop then took
a totem and seemingly used it throughout
the movie as a way to assess whether he
was in the real world or not each
character is told to use a personal item
they only know the truth about and thus
people won't be able to trap them in a
dream having knowledge of someone's
possession allows an extraction to go
ahead and we actually see this
demonstrated early in the film sato's
secret love nest is recreate in full
detail but the carpet fabric being wrong
is what gives it away but this was a
fault due to the lack of research but it
shows how knowing your totems the way to
tell what's real characters are supposed
to keep these items to themselves and
were told in the film that you shouldn't
touch another's totem how about that
Rule's broken and the fact that the
spinning top belonged to Mal also shows
why it's unlikely that he'd ever use it
now in 2020 I theorized Cobb's Titan was
actually his wedding ring and this
pretty much confirms that it's always
been the case again throughout the movie
whenever he's in a dream you can catch
the character wearing it on his left
hand and this is because in the dream
Mal's still alive now on this watch
through I actually kept a close eye on
his left hand and I noticed that he
tends to hide it when he's with the
group it's always kind of placed out of
the way and it's such a clever way to
show that in the end this is actually
his true totem completely paranoid it
makes sense he'd have a second way to
check and this is in case a totem
topples over now if someone was able to
intercept him and they knew that he used
to Totem then they could probably try
and replicate it just like the carpet so
the Rings is real one and this is just
in case it ever comes to a point where
he needs that reassurance now Nolan
stated at the end that when he comes
across his family he leaves it up
spinning for a specific reason normally
cardboard completely obsess over it but
the fact he doesn't care to look shows
that it doesn't matter he's finally
happy and back with his fam Lee and
whether it's a dream or not it doesn't
matter to him however if we check his
hand we can see that it's the real world
and that the character made it home and
back to his family look who's here
now it's possible that there's a secret
Inception in the film and that the
team's actually there to get cop to
finally leave his dreams in order to do
this though he has to leave Mal behind
and take the job which flies him out to
the US now in order to discuss this we
have to look at what Inception is and
how it also fits what happens to him in
the movie we learn that in order for
Inception to work it has to be inspired
and that you can't just plow tell
someone what you want them to think we
see this demonstrated on Fisher and this
happens when they reinforce the idea
that his father actually wanted him to
break up the company although this Saga
believes they've decided to do it
themselves they're actually manipulated
into it by the use of repetition now we
will discuss all the instances where
this happens with Bishop of a Cobb
there's a number of Clues throughout
Bruce Lee is the big song that plays in
the movie which is known as Jenna regret
Brienne I butchered that but it's French
Tunes dropped in a signal to the team
that a Kick's about to happen on the
surface it's a nice little song but it
actually holds a lot of meaning behind
it the song is very much an
inspirational one and it's about someone
letting go of all the regrets that they
have in their life Frank Sinatra did a
play on this for his Infamous song My
Way But A lot's going on in the original
version that hints towards cop
psychology the song is actually about
having no regrets and leaving the past
behind something that the protagonist
refuses to do because of his wife's
death Cobb even has an elevator that
provides access to flaws filled with
regret and in the end it's clear he has
a lot he'd like to change however as we
close out he finally let's go and
reunites with his family shedding the
idea of Mal which is held him back
throughout the film he's moving on to
something else and the team playing this
song could be them subliminally telling
him to move on from Mal the singer is
French herself and in a nice little
tie-in Marion cult yard actually played
her in a film now whether it's
intentional or not this idea of a French
woman singing about having no regrets it
could be something that could sign with
Mal the whole movie is basically built
around her and even early on we see a
picture by artist Francis Bay chicken
this was actually when the artist
created after the death of his lover and
he and Cobb both share some striking
similarities the Warped face on it
symbolized that he was unable to fully
recreate his lost love which is
something that carb also says to Mal I
can't imagine you with all your
complexity all your Perfection all your
imperfections another big moment is a
line that Miles has in the film come
back to reality Tom
at the time this is pretty much a
throwaway line but it could be
reinforcing the notion that Cobb needs
to come back we see a similar tactic
used in the film at one point when it's
hinted official that his father wanted
him to be his own man it'd be the end of
the entire Empire as we know it
let's try my whole inheritance
why would he suggest such a thing
similar to the miles moment this is a
throwaway line but it's dropped so that
when Fisher gets deeper into the dream
it's something that he stews upon
throughout life there will be things
that people say to you that neither of
you pay that much attention to at the
time but there'll be something that you
constantly think about because of what
implications they have for example if
you have an argument with your ex before
you break up she might say some that
sticks with you like you'll never have a
million subscribers but uh it'll keep
powering you on and I promise mate
you'll eventually get there
now going back to how this could be an
Inception on carb when he says goodbye
to his wife it's even similar to how
Fisher says goodbye to his father both
must let them go and Fishes father dies
similar how Mal does upon cop
confronting her so he can't see that one
throwaway line art had in a seemingly
meaningless moment can be built upon the
further into the dream you go now the
clues include that Cobb seems to exist
in a reality that's very much like a
dream where he's chased by projections
said to be an agency they act much like
the subconscious and try to take him
down at several points thus this entire
thing could just be another layout with
a team breaking in to make him think
that he has to return home on top of
this saito's arguably the person that
actually adds to the theory of Cobb
having to let go this is because there's
a line that's repeating throughout the
movie and he says do you want to take a
leap of faith
or become an old man
filled with Rigby I'm an old man
felt a regret
similar to a three-layer dream this
forces Cobb to question whether he wants
to live the rest of his life built with
regret alone and away from his family or
if he wants to go back if he holds on to
the idea of Mal then he'll definitely
end up like that and he'll forever be
fleeing from the enigmatic agents I
think the old man fell with regret line
is very similar to the line about coming
back to reality and the end of the movie
in which cop comes face to face with
Silo could be a revelation of that here
he sits opposite an old lonely man and
Cobb literally sees his own fate laid
out before him now this happens after
his conversation with Mal but it still
shows that he's now seeing things that
will continue to make him travel down
the path at this point and he needs to
escape the dream curb could remain here
but he's told to take a leap of faith to
return to the real world and finally be
back with his family now another
interesting line Mal says is
be crawl together
and this is something it's kept Cobb
holding on to her it was one of their
wedding vows but the conversation at the
end makes Cobb finally realize that they
actually did the pair lived a lifetime
together deep down in the dream and once
he finally realizes this he's able to
let go raws are told in the film that a
positive idea works better than a
negative one and this too may be the
reason why the end feels like such a win
for him when we look at it for what it
really is the true Inception was putting
the idea on his head that he should
leave all his regrets behind and return
home so that might be the hidden
Inception in the film but let me know
below what you think as we get into the
movie now one of the coolest Easter eggs
that's been spotted in the film is the
fact that if you take the character's
names first letters they spell out dream
pays this is because Dom Robert Eames
Arthur Mal Saito Peter ariadne and
Youssef they spell dreams pay now the
names also have specific meanings
attached to dreams and how the
characters operate in the film Cobb
means dream in Sanskrit and it's also
named Nolan used in his first film
titled the following this starred Alex
Hall who's also an architect in real
life his first name darm also means home
in Polish and the other characters share
deeper layers too ariadne is actually
from an ancient Greek myth and the name
comes from the story Theseus and the
Minotaur in the story she helped Theseus
Escape The Maze and in the film she does
the same thing with cop ariadnez someone
who builds maces as well which we see
her doing on the job in the film now
Yusef is the Arabic version of Joseph
who's someone that interpreted the
pharaoh's dreams when we look at the
Bible Eames is another charlson but he's
eems who are credited as revolutionaries
in industrial and modern architecture
Fisher and his father have some cool
things too as Maurice Fisher is an odd
to M.C Escher his full name was Maurice
Cornelius Escher whose work inspired
some of the visual effects his son
Robert is named after Bobby Fischer who
was also a champion chess player now the
name Fisher itself may be a nod to the
legends of King Arthur and this is due
to the similarities that streams have
two fishes Kingdom the wounds that the
characters received were reflected in
his castle and throughout the film the
landscape shifts depending on how he is
mentally Arthur may be a nut of this as
well and originally James Franco was in
talks to play the character however
Joseph gordon-levich showed up to the
audition wearing a suit and as soon as
they saw him like that they knew that he
was perfect hamal can also mean ill in
French Spanish and Portuguese and this
could be referring to how she acts as a
sickness that's still up for debate but
the cast and characters themselves also
reflect a lot of Nolan's career during
an interview with Entertainment Weekly
he talked about how they rolled an
Inception with some of that of
filmmaking Cub is a director Arthur
producers and ariadne is considered the
set design Kobe even dresses like how
Nolan does throughout the movie and he
could sort of be seen as herself into it
I know that's a dirty word these days
but a lot of time when people are
crafting stories they do often put
themselves in it to help flesh out the
world either way eems plays different
roles but because he's an actor and
cytos the studio that's in control
lastly fish is seen as being the
audience and you can tell Nolan pulled
from his own experience in order to
craft these roles anyway that takes us
into the movie itself which opens with
Cobb washing up on the shore in the
middle of the film Cobb talks us through
her dream's work and he says you never
really remember the beginning of a dream
do you always wind up right in the
middle of what's going on this is very
much how the movie opens as well and
Nolan said he wanted the film to open up
much like a dream for the viewer the end
credits of the film reflect this too
when the tunnel text Inception appears
three times in the credits this is meant
to represent the three layers and as we
watch the text pop up we're coming
further out of the dream that the
movie's taken us through on the show we
see Cubs children for the first time but
he refuses to look at them this is
because he knows that if he does he may
be tempted to remain in the dream with
them the vision of Mal was a temptress
too who wanted to keep him in this
reality and I think that she purposely
represented a siren in case you don't
know according to the myths these were
apparently beautiful women that would
sing to Sailors at Sea and in the end
they'd lure them to their debt I don't
think it's a coincidence that this
opening takes place on a beach and the
location as the kids also building sand
castles this is something we see both
cob and Mal doing during their time in
limbo and this was the pair constructing
their dream world what about the
children were never there which is what
called them back and I love how we have
this echo of iconography now covers
taking usaido's palace and this is the
same location Arthur constructed for him
when they first met as we know all of
the dreamers subconscious can exist down
on this layer and it makes a lot of
sense how he was able to copy it so well
I love the cut back and forth between
these two times without any warning and
just like a dream things happen without
explanation Sado says are you here to
kill me which we know in fact is due to
that being how one escapes the dream
Sato carefully examines the top and
Spins it and him touching it once more
shows that this can't be cops real token
anyway we could have the past and and C
Cub carrying out a high sunseto's
corporate plans for all of his
competitors this is known as extraction
and it involves stealing secrets from
someone's subconscious during dreams
people's sense of logic and perception
is lowered and thus in the end they're
easier to manipulate we see this is the
case here too with just the mention of a
secret causing side of the look over to
where the safe is hidden instantly his
mind builds this with knowledge and the
pitch allows them to complete the first
part of their plan Nolan brilliantly
shows us how time moves differently
depending on the layers as we cut to a
watch in seeds speeding up on this layer
is Nash's subconscious which is
currently running riots searching for
the dreamers working like antibodies
they know someone's in his mind and will
do whatever they can to get rid of the
group now this Devastation on the
surface is affecting things up top and
to make things worse Mal's entered the
dream as we know she died by jumping
from a hide and we somewhat get a little
nut to her actions with her first line
if I turn
no work by bacon Mal says looks like
Arthur's taste and as we discussed
earlier the character is somewhat based
on the idea bacon was bringing across
here now the coloring and distortion on
the face looks familiar it's because
Nolan used Bacon's work as a basis for
his Joker it adds an extra Dimension to
the Sea now we can see his cops Torn
Between the mission and her do the
children miss me
[Music]
now from this point he starts working
his way through the compound and Cobb
uses a silencer to keep himself hidden
to be extra safe he also puts his hand
over the gun to catch the cartridge as
it rolling on the floor will make more
noise a cub gets the secrets but he's
caught by Saito who was informed of what
they were doing by Mal as we know miles
an extension of Cobb and there's
actually a cool little moment here which
gives that away when cider discovers
that Cobb managed to steal his Secrets
Mal can actually be seen smiling for a
split second showing she's happy Got
Away now as the dream collapses cob has
to check the secrets out before it comes
crashing down and this is such an
outstanding way to open up the movie
what is used to Great effects yet it
instantly wakes someone up and if you've
ever had a glass of water chucked over
you as you're sleeping then you'll know
what I mean
anyway after things go down worse than a
YouTube apology with a ukulele cob and
Co wake up on board a train Cobb leaves
as quickly as he can and he says well
he's not gonna check every compartment I
don't like trains now in the movie we
learned that he and his wife used to
train as a way to kill them so that they
could wake up Cobb is constantly
tormented by this train and it shows up
in the movie at very awkward moments the
train carries a number 3502 on it and we
actually discovered that this was the
room that he and his wife spent the
anniversary in another number which
appears in the film is 528491 and Fisher
comes up with this random sequence when
he's later questioned the first six
numbers that come to your head right now
right now
now I said right now
five
five eight four nine one
it then appears as the blonde lady from
westworld's phone number and it's also
part of the room numbers that the team
stay in the top room is 528 and the room
directly below it is 491 now eventually
this all pays off and in the end Fisher
opens to safe with the code
528-491 the soundtrack also has a track
titled 528491 on it and if we look at
the titles of the songs then these words
are all a specific length the words get
shorter and shorter as we go into the
middle of the soundtrack because the
characters are going deeper into the
dream however as they go further out of
it they then start to expand and this
represents the characters now exiting it
now if this hasn't blown your mind then
you should also know that hashtag
528491 can be used as a hex color code
to display the shade of sign which was
used on a lot of branding in the movie
now in a heartbreaking phone call with
his kids we see just how torn up copies
are when not being able to see them
Nolan's often been criticized for the
lack of humanity in his movies and this
is something a lot of people levied
towards tenet Leo felt this was the same
with the script for Inception and once
he was cast he actually spent months
with Nolan working on the screenplay
Emma Thomas stated the work DiCaprio did
on his character with Chris made the
movie less of a puzzle and more of a
story a character audiences could relate
to now after being offered a job by Sato
he someone gives cop the idea that if he
works for him he can go and see his kids
again we also get Arthur explaining how
Inception works I say to you don't think
about elephants what do you about
elephants right but it's not your idea
because you know I gave it to you and
this is actually and I did the book
don't think of an elephant by George
lakov jujit adds to Reddit user x24ax or
pointing this out and the book itself is
about conceptual framing it talks about
how certain words can be used to give
someone a certain idea which Arthur also
thumbs up clearly discussing here now
Cobb then goes to Michael Kane who at
this point is a Nolan mainstay I love
the guy and it may surprise you to learn
that he actually only gets three minutes
of screen time in the entire movie
introduced to Ariana cup puts her
through her Paces anything gets there to
go and designer maze now we see elephant
in the room is that the ACT is now
Elliot page so I'm just gonna refer to
the character by their name and she and
her due to the character being female no
disrespect intended uh yeah just gotta
get that out the way and initially he
gives her an outpad with a grid on it
drawing a rectangular maze she fails
time and time again because the Grid in
their structures are holding her back
though she flips the notepad around and
draws it on the back of the pad now we
can see here there's no lines to guide
her these were subconsciously how she
drew the maze but not having them here
allows her to think more freely Cobb
also can't tear this like it's a bit of
paper and because it makes the base of
the book it can't just be ripped out and
one thing we pointed out in our last
breakdown is that the first circular
maze they get doesn't actually have a
way that you can solve it the entrances
are blocked off and a lot of structures
that the Architects build aren't
actually solvable they're just there to
look nice now when planning out how
they're going to carry out their Heist
they spend the majority of the scenes
deep down in the dream world this is
because time works differently in a
dream and using the time dilation that's
present they have longer to plan the
mission this idea of time working
differently is something that people
have had fun with outside of the movie
and Cable listings even had the film
saying it runs for two days and nine
hours this is how long it would be if it
was watched in a dream and it gives the
teams so much more time and the film we
learned that 10 seconds in the first
Lair comes out at roughly three minutes
with this then being an hour when we get
to the next layer IMDb trivia actually
has the entire equation for this mapped
out and it states that time expands
roughly 18 times every layer going over
the numbers behind it it means that
every 10 seconds is roughly seven and a
half days on the lowest level thus 50
years would be around 10 and a half
hours sleep meaning that carbon mile
just had a bit of a lie in now this is
why cyto became an old man during the
flight time that they have during the
mission also I think it's worth pointing
out that Kenwood and Obi and Nolan
worked together on Batman Begins but
Nolan regretted him having such a small
role as he gave him a much bigger part
in this movie and it of course opened
the doors for films in the west like
Godzilla and so on now walking through
Paris ariadne starts to pull the city in
on itself leading to one of the coolest
and most unique effects in the entire
movie it might surprise you to learn
that the movie only actually has 500
visual effects shots in it with Nolan
preferring to do as much as he could in
the camera practically this included
things like the Penrose steps and zero
gravity sequences which were all done
without CGI they actually saved a lot on
the budget by giving ariadne a bun and
this meant that her hair stayed in place
during these sequences hair and zero
gravity is a tough thing to animate and
it's also why brand is short hair in
interstellar now after demonstrating the
dangers of subconscious we then meetings
played by Tom Hardy when we come across
the character we can see him gambling
now we watch as he loses his hand
however he still goes up with two full
stacks of chips Which cot picks up and
then starts to examine he says his
spelling hasn't improved and that's
because these chips he's cashing in are
actually fake as we pointed out in our
first video the Mombasa has two s's in
it and you son of a you couldn't
even get that right it talk about how
cobal engineering is after him and we
see some of their agents situate at the
bar the Cobalt job is actually a prequel
comic for the film and it ends with them
going on the job to try and steal from
Saito Chase through the streets as we
mentioned earlier this has made many
believe that these agents are actually
projections the streets of the city
actually acts and what like a maze and
when we see the skyline at the start it
resembles this too there's definitely
that feeling here and I love how Nolan
uses this to mess with our minds now
after he saved by Sato we then go meet
Yusuf who works with chemicals and also
sedatives you might notice his cat
climbing around and licking a pop beside
him and this actually sets up a nice
joke in the next scene the next time we
see the cat it's asleep so we can kind
of guess what was in that in the
basement we see the final performance by
El Cameron who at the time of release
was 92 years old he passed away 10 years
after filming this and even with his one
line he does a lot with so little now
these are supposed to reflect open dens
and people who've become addicted to
living in their dreams girl's character
says
who are you today
and again this has made people think
that Cubs stuck in a dream now it's not
too long before we learn the inner
workings of fish's organization and I
love how you can catch Eames certainly
sitting off to the side Maury smashes a
photo of him and Robert as a child and
they actually did something very small
with the makeup yeah that young Maurice
in the photo is actually Killian Murphy
wearing a wig and fake mustache and this
was to make it seem like the characters
were actually related slowly things slot
into place and we see ariad name mapping
out the dreams behind her we can
actually see the tower from the snow
base and later on this appears in full
effect this is actually based on the
exterior of the geyser library at the
University of California showing how
Ariana pulled in some inspiration from
real life now the entire snow scene was
actually based on Nolan's favorite Bond
movie which surprisingly is on Her
Majesty's Secret Service not one of the
best uh but yeah whatever helped to
inspire this amazing film director the
Nolan purposely used his own favorite
films to inspire the different dream
levels because like I said this is kind
of a metaphor for filmmaking when
crafting a movie directors often
bringing work that's inspired them and
these elements of this to flesh out
their creation this is the same way in
which an architect pulls from their own
life but they should never out now copy
the things that they've seen filmmakers
have to deal with this too and the idea
of plagiarism slash inspiration is of
course a debate that people have today
no Nolan has taken this idea to inspire
the layers and the busy city streets are
inspired by heat the Michael Mann
classical so heavily influenced the Dark
Knight and it's often said that Nolan's
Styles very similar to his the hotel
layout was also inspired by The Shining
and it was so cool pouring through the
behind the scenes stuff to find these
things out now ariadne lifts up a model
of the Maze and this iconography appears
throughout the entire film not only were
the streets of Mombasa just like this
but we also see the limber level polls
from this as well the buildings at Mount
the shore extend out like a maze and
there's this constant repetition that's
popping up Cobb doesn't want to see the
players though because malcol could
sabotage it and we see this happening
later on in the film left in a desperate
position they have to open up about a
shortcut which cop finding out that
informs Mal it's clear as baggage is
causing a lot of issues but he swears
it's not even though we all know how
hello wives ruin everything look at
looking at you Yoko Ono
oh here we go again now the
brainstorm the idea that they want to
plan and discuss how this has to be
placed deep in the subconscious we see a
newspaper article drop down and if you
look closely at it the word for that is
leaping off the page subconsciously this
emphasizes how important that the dad is
and the other culture follow this Hammer
home their relationship the one on the
left side talks about Maurice and Robert
who apparently had a full-blown argument
at a trendy restaurant on the other side
of this it talks about Peter Browning
but the bottom paragraph actually holds
the most importance the Beast mentions
how nepotism is a big factor in business
and how Browning will likely be pushed
out because of who Robert is it talks
about our brownings but his life's blood
into the business but because Robert's
got the last name he's probably gonna
inherit it it kinda goes in on Robert
and suggests that he doesn't have the
murder ability and if we look at this
like it's a con job then Robert's
definitely the mark he basically comes
out getting con because Sada needs him
to destroy the company so that he can
dominate the market and then take over
it's corporate Espionage but these
elements all come in place to use
Robert's inability to lead is what
brings it down had Browning got the
company it likely wouldn't have fallen
apart but Maurice choosing his son leads
to its downfall at him being chosen
helps to implant the idea that his dad
actually wanted him to be his own man we
know that's not the case though as in
reality Maurice viewed him as being a
disappointment you could barely speak
he took the trouble
to tell me one last thing
disappointed I'm guessing on his
deathbed he was too over it to change as
well I only do talk about power of
attorney so the will was potentially
drafted up years prior or maybe didn't
have one and Maurice may regret what his
son turned out like kind of feel bad
saying this because I actually I like
Robert as well but yeah something about
this watch through May that stand out
for me I must say it's the first time
I've ever thought about it like that and
maybe I'm an ex-watch I will see things
differently what I love about this film
is that every time you go back to it you
do see something different and it really
adds to the draw of what Nolan's created
now as they start to put things in place
we see the group standing around in the
streets as ariadne slowly Maps out the
terrain going back to the filmmaking
metaphor this could be seen as a set
with them putting things in place before
the actors come in I love how in the
background you can see things slotting
down and sada's expression In This
Moment is absolutely great guy's never
seen anything like this before and he
looks around and wonder while Sailors
don't now they later stand around in the
hotel lobby too and it shows how they
went to these locations before carrying
out the job now whilst this is going on
Yusuf explains the kick in how a falling
sensation can be used to wake you up
it's something they of course do when
they're on the bridge and when they're
down in limbo and they jump from the
skyscrapers I'm sure we will experience
falling in a dream and this sensation
normally snaps you out of it however it
has a deeper meaning mainly tied to Mal
and how she decided to go and end it all
Mal of course jumped out of a window and
taking her life and this was probably to
give her the sensation of falling it of
course killed her too but we later see
our jumping from buildings can wake
someone up now during this she talks
about taking a leap of faith which is
something that side out also said to
Cobb I'm asking you to take a leap of
faith do you want to take a leap of
faith
or become an old man
filled with Rigby waiting to die alone
it all ties into the idea of regret and
may have been used to reinforce the idea
that Cobbs should go back home I love
the scene set in Cub's elevator of
Torment as well and it's something that
we all have that's built within us I
don't mean a literal elevator but I
can't tell you the knights that I've set
up thinking about the past but rather
than staying awake Cobb handles it in a
dream he spends his nights today dead
going back through his memories
desperate to return to the life he used
to have
Can't Let Her Go now he watches ariadne
descends down and passes by a dollhouse
which we Layla lens wear cobbed at the
Inception we also see them together and
Mal says you said you had a dream
someone crawled together which is
something we pointed out that she says
later on but it's all seized as a way to
tone cob in his nightmares
together
great jump scare here as well with her
turning her head and it reminded me of
Nolan doing the one in The Dark Knight
about you and me
the one thing that people hung on to
with the whole is a real slash is it a
dream thing is where Ariana brings up
not using real places on the next floor
we're taking the cops home and at the
end this is where he returns to again I
don't think it's really the case but you
can see how using real places can lead
to confusion we see his Club regrets not
seeing his kids faces for the last time
and he's given a ticket to quickly leave
the country a clue here that the ending
is real is also the fact that Cobb's son
gets slightly older and this is actually
played by Nolan's real life son anyway
ariadne makes a break for it and rushes
to the elevator which is when she sees a
train before heading the hotel here we
see what happened and how Mal trashed
the room to make it seem like Cobb
actually caused her death now speaking
of death we hear how Maurice passed away
and now it's the time that the group
need to strike rubber will be flying out
soon Inside Out buys the airline to
bring it all together eem swipes his
passport so cop can do a classic command
trick which is to find a way to to
introduce himself and also seem like a
nice guy passing his passport here he
also incepts his water which allows the
character to drug him oh that before he
does this he talks about his dad and he
says well he was a very inspiring
for your loss this is the first part of
the Inception with the focus on the
inspiring figure being used as a way to
plant the idea that is that's inspiring
as we know Inception has to be inspired
and it's from this point that they enter
the first layer it's raining because
Youssef needs a Wii and due to him being
the dreamer the world's influence by him
that includes a car later on and they
actually chose the song on the radio
here because they said that's what
Yousef would listen to
also before they bum into this taxi we
can see the number on the back and this
reads 2053 this is actually a reverse of
the number three five zero two which as
we said before appears on the train now
a cool little detail in all that is that
all the cars here have their own unique
state motto the phrase the alternate
State appears on them all and this is
used as a way to describe dreaming now
after the projections swarm them we
learn Fischer has Security in place and
to make matters worse the train comes
piling in no one someone did this for
real and they used to train with real
car tires on it in order to create the
look now speaking of creating the luck
we see Eames adopting Browning and
although they can catch him slowly
changing his luck the mirror slowly drop
seems his reflection as the truth comes
out and it's such a cool way to show the
transformation with the train causing
issues Cobb starts to confide in ariadne
and we see some Snippets of their life
and how it happened in limbo Cobb
enjoyed feeling like a god but he wasn't
fully involved in it because deep down
in New that it wasn't real however miles
somewhat wanted to remain there which is
why she locked away her totem this lady
used to convince her that nothing was
real and cop pushing the boundaries
ultimately caused to death now we do get
some foreshadowing of what their debts
were like when we see from Cobb's POV as
the pair both wake up they lie in
similar positions to how they did on the
track with Miles had even been like how
it was before the train hit after the
projections descent on the location we
see his aim somewhat gives Arthur an
idea
you mustn't be afraid to dream a little
bigger darling
he shows some explosives can help which
is what Arthur later uses in order to
supply the kick as Yousef races to the
bridge the team descend further and they
put a plan in place called Mr Charles
this involves telling the dreamer that
they're in a dream and it makes a Target
then lower their God his projections are
immediately suspicious though and we can
actually catch a god at the bar staring
directly at him he gets up and follows
him as he walks out and pointing out
that he was the woman makes vicious
start to trust him telling him he's
dreaming we then watches the hotel
shifts and rain starts to come in from
the layer right above in a really nice
detail when the gravity goes back to
normal you can catch Cobb was balancing
himself against fish's stool now kind of
jumping back a bit but on the napkin we
can see the hotel's name is Hotel
valfieno Eduardo De valfieno was
allegedly a con man who put together a
group that stole the Mona Lisa in 1911.
apparently he wished to make copies of
it to sell him off to six buyers but the
group were caught and the painting was
returned in 1913 now there's actually no
evidence that Eduardo actually existed
so this is a coolant Easter egg for the
name of the hotel now as the group in
the dream make their way to the compound
we watch his other sets of the kick on
the middle layer you set drives to the
bridge so that it can get a high enough
drop and he actually flips the
projections off as he reverses back
sometimes I do this to the police as I'm
driving past him and a nice little
detail that I appreciate now the way
that the scenes are edited is also a
very similar technique to what Nolan
would later use in his movie Dunkirk the
top level scenes time length wise are
shorter than the middle which in turn
are shorter than the bottom level so
just as time gets longer the further
down we go on the levels the length of
the scenes also does too a zero gravity
is used throughout the hotel and like
ariadna's hair this caused issues
planning out the set however they
realize that hotel staff tended took the
blankets and pillows in really tight so
they wouldn't float around when the
hotel is moving about thus when Arthur
enters the things floating a solid
objects whereas CGI blankets would have
been to to animate the other clothes is
the case before moving things about and
this is to stop the atoms in place from
going everywhere Arthur also uses the
Penrose steps to take out a projection
and this is a technique that he
demonstrated before this seemingly
looping staircase is a callback to MCS
here and it allows Arthur to get the
drop on them I'll swear we see an
avalanche hit caused by the Apple layers
and Fisher says
have dropped off a goddamn Beach
as we know Cobb did actually dream up a
beach but it wasn't exactly Sunshine In
Rainbows no cyto and Fisher end up
taking a hidden pathway and this acts as
a shortcut through the level however on
the way Fisher turns his radio off and
this is due to it making a static noise
[Music]
that brings with it some consequences as
a later con warning that Miles sneaking
in also I love when Eames Chucks the
explosive at the Sonoma Bill and he does
a little thumbs up as he drives off you
should thumbs up the video and subscribe
as well because it's a play it's a
bloody good channel here anyway after
fish is killed on this layout we see his
carbonari adenai descend into limbo
along the shore we can see buildings
crumbling away and the creative team
said that this represents memories in
our subconscious I slowly diminish after
time and they get lost in the ocean of
our brains in this reality we find the
world that the pair built with the
architecture getting more complex the
further they go on the buildings
initially start off small before
evolving into skyscrapers and the
designs themselves shift to mimic
building work over the last 50 years now
as they get further in we see how the
homes the pair grew up and have been
recreated but they now look like they're
completely falling apart this is because
as the memory of them Fades they slowly
start to rot and eventually Decay leads
to a heartbreaking moment in a room in
their home in which Cobb finally decides
to move on from Mal I don't think it's
any coincidence either that this is the
room in which he finally leaves the top
and it represents the place that he
starts a new chapter he leaves Mal here
and then leaves the top and it's from
this location that he finally steps
forward also they kind of jump about
with the pronunciation of Mal and Maul
in the movie so apologies if you've been
in the comments furiously hammering away
that I've been saying are wrong it's
just me be stupid Northern England
accent and this mile is short for
Mallory so I've just stated with that
ruin the entire video for you there but
uh yeah he finally says goodbye to her
but he remains behind to find Sado
whilst Fisher and ariadne escape on the
upper level Fisher comes face to face
with his father who's muttering away the
final words that he heard him say
this
is
however in the dream the circumstances
can be changed and Maurice gives more
dialogue to tell him to be his own man
inside the safe he finds a new world
along with a windmill laddy blue in the
fall together this image is summing up
Robert placed by his deathbed because he
cared about it rather Maurice doing it
thus bringing this across it inspires
him further and just like the forever
spinning top being inside the safe this
windmill coming from one implanted in
his mind now the kicks start to get put
in place and we see as cop goes to Saito
I love the focus on the spinning top
which never Falls over and as we know
this is due to it being a dream Sado
could stay with this and remain in the
dream forever but instead his hand moves
towards the gun to wake them both up on
the plane we watch as they all come to
and I don't know just something about
seeing them all kind of look at each
other really cements the big Journey
they've gone on also forgot to mention
before but the flight attendants
actually played by Nolan's cousin who's
called Miranda Nolan anyway remembering
his promise Sado makes the call and we
see his car jobs welcome to America
welcome home Mr Cub
thank you still get goosebumps now
watching him return home and unlike the
locations in the dream we actually see
Cobb arriving here this confirms it's
real and as he moves through to meet
Michael Kane we can also catch a sign
that says Fisher which is a nice little
detail entering his home we see blocks
looking like a house on the table and
can hear his children talking about
building a house on the cliffs
this could end towards his son following
in his mother and Father's Footsteps as
an architect and we close out on that
outstanding final shot
huh
that wraps up this incredible movie and
huge thank you for going back through
with me I've had such a blast talking
about this film and to me it's one of
Nolan's many many masterpieces this was
the movie that shoddy could create his
own Concepts and build something I would
Define a cinematic generation everything
about this film's influenced so many
after it and even the trailer for a
change the way that trailers were edited
can't even count how many times the bomb
sound was used and even though God
played out I still love it because of
this movie
foreign
and I hope you've had a good time going
back through it too and if we missed
anything then make sure you drop it
below if you want to support the channel
for as little as 99 cents a month then
please click the join button below and
as a thank you get early access to these
videos if you want to see us break down
more Nola movies then definitely check
out our video on Interstellar along with
a Prestige which will be linked on
screen now but either way it's been a
dream going through this video I'm off
to spend some time with my kids and I
hope to see you next time you take care
enjoy the rest of your week and have a
good one mate peace
thank you
[Music]
foreign